kursk Assad is the channel people most
often point to as the channel that does
it right in a YouTube environment where
many other educational channels are
pumping out several videos every single
day in order to maximize revenue kursk
Assad has stuck to their philosophy of
quality over quantity posting only once
or twice a month they have even taken
down some of their most popular videos
after getting feedback that some other
information they used in the video was
inaccurate this is all great and all but
what's 37 in-house employees is this
actually economically viable or have
they just been burning through money
trying to keep this channel alive
usually 4-channel estimates I low balled
estimates but curse Cassatt is special
considering that they only post once or
twice a month
they likely seek out the best sponsors
have the most loyal Patriot members and
have high affiliate conversion rates
keeping this in mind let's start with
their ad revenue education channels
generally have the highest CPMs on
youtube averaging between 5 to $10 per
thousand views now kurzgesagt does have
really in detail videos but their videos
do cover a broad range of topics one of
the videos could be about space and
their follow up video could be about
overpopulation this wide range of topics
is not the most advertiser friendly but
their depth in each topic does make them
quite appealing so generally we would
give them a CPM of 8 but there is one
issue most of the videos don't cross the
10-minute mark and even for videos that
do they don't put in mid-roll ads so
they've likely only get a CPM of about 5
given that they have been driving 25 or
30 million views per month aside from
the pandemic spike with an average of
twenty seven point five million views a
month Adsense would give them 137
thousand five hundred dollars every
single month ask for video sponsor and
affiliate marketing I was going to
estimate them based on Curtis arts
videos over the past year or month as
that's what I do with other channels
however curse Cassatt only has 119
videos in total so I just decided to go
through all of them on average sponsors
pay between 3 and 15 cents per view with
an average of 8.9 cents so to set this
up I said that classic sponsors like
audible dashlane and curiosity stream
paid 10 cents per view or a little above
average and I said that nonprofit
foundations and government organizations
paid 5 cents per view as they have less
of an incentive to sponsor this gave a
sponsorship revenue of 30 2.6 million
dollars over their entire channel ask
for the affiliate marketing the average
online click-through rate for sponsored
videos is between 4 and 7 percent
but the Kyrgyz our audience is quite
loyal so I thought they would get an
above-average
6% CTR for the actual conversion rate
however I gave them an average 3% for
the Commission itself these generally
range between five and ten dollars per
sale and some even go up as high as one
or dollars per sale like from Wix but
since we've been giving Kyrgyz on edge
so far let's play this one conservative
and give them an average Commission of
five dollars this comes out to a total
of thirty four point eight million
dollars over the past five years looking
after a total video views' graph over
the past three years we can see that
there are quite linear they don't have
any random spikes and they're quite
consistent so we can say this revenue
was coming in regularly over the past
five years translating to about 540
thousand dollars per month in
sponsorships and $40,000 per month in
affiliate marketing revenue and that
leaves us with patreon and merchandise
sales asked for patreon the median
commitment across patreon is six dollars
and seventy cents
however the median commitment across all
online support platforms is actually
twelve dollars a month
given the loyalty of the kursk as our
audience it's quite possible that the
average commitment is much higher than
both of these at fifteen to twenty
dollars a month
for instance the $150 per month
commitment is sold out and there one
hurdle is per month commitment only has
14 spots left but we'll play it safe and
called the online average of 12 hours a
month with 14,000 450 patrons this comes
out to one hundred and seventy three
thousand four hundred dollars a month
and finally for merchandise sales so
Murtaugh org suggests that the average
youtuber gets about six units and sales
and profits about $70 per month of
merchandise sales for every 11,000
subscribers sell merch also suggests
that these numbers can be significantly
improved with the right type of
subscribers and style designs and I
think we agreed that kursk assad has
this in the bag so well bump the ratio
up to $100 per 10,000 subscribers what
about 12 million subscribers
this comes out to $120,000 a month now
we do have one more clue about their
earnings in an article written by Kursk
assualt themselves they revealed that
sponsorships account for about 20
percent of their income now this was
three years ago and looking at the
spreadsheets we can see that they are
shifted towards sponsorship from
companies rather than foundations and
the government so sponsorships likely
make up for a larger portion of their
income today we'll call it 33% if the
sponsorship estimate is accurate and the
other estimates are low balling it then
kursk azad could be making about 1.6 2
million dollars a month however if the
sponsorship estimate is too high and the
other estimates are more accurate then
their income per month would still be at
least $700,000
considering this Carissa Posen write
about 800,000 to 1.2 million dollars per
month or about 1 million dollars per
month so even if they paid all 36 of
their employees $10,000 a month and
spent 140 thousand dollars a month on
office space Wi-Fi subscriptions music
production hardware and so on and so
forth they would still be left with 500
thousand dollars a month in profit the
German corporate tax rate is 15 point 8
to 5 percent meaning of the owner would
have a net profit of 420 thousand
dollars per month or about 5 million
dollars a year this would value the
company at about 50 million dollars and
as expand into different languages like
German and Spanish this number is simply
going to go up kurzgesagt may have
struggled for the first few years but
today yes Curtis OTT is not only
profitable but also lucrative allowing
the founder of Philip Detmer to enjoy a
nice multiple seven-figure income but
for a channel that's always focused on
content and the audience I think the
income is more than well-deserved do you
guys agree comment that down below also
if you guys thought this video provided
a thorough analysis of course Cassatt's
income that makes you drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm hari and I'll see you guys on
the night
one